bonjour bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de parlement hebdo en compagnie qu'elle
a metz bonjour michael le mariage pour
tous toujours dans l'actualité cette
semaine premier mariage symbole célébrée
à montpellier entre bruno et vincent
devant 500 invités 200 journalistes dans
cette émission nous verrons comment
l'ump compte transformer l'essai dans
les urnes mais aussi continue à se
diviser
un petit coup de chaussée nord plein
débat sur la réforme des collectivités
les avis de tous bords s'opposent aux
projets on a même assisté un petit clash
entre la ministre marylise lebranchu est
une élue socialiste pas vraiment sur la
même longueur d'onde
enfin la commission de bruxelles fait
part de ses recommandations aux mauvais
élèves français si la france veut tu un
délai pour respecter les objectifs de
bruxelles elle va devoir engager des
réformes structurelles
ce n'est pas bruxelles qui dicte notre
politique répond françois hollande
bonjour claude goasguen bonjour vous
êtes avec nous pour tout au long de
cette émission députés de l'ump maire du
xvième arrondissement alors on va
évidemment regardé développer toute
cette actualité dans un instant mais en
cette fin de semaine nous avait dû avoir
les oreilles qui ont un petit peu sifflé
vous avez été nommément mises en cause
par un candidat ump à la municipale à
paris en dida qui s'appelle
jean-françois legaret pour une histoire
de vidéo de fichiers il faut propose de
regarder les faits et on en discute
juste après voici la vidéo qui a mis le
feu aux poudres
un anniversaire
jean françois legaret replier présenté
comme une girouette qui soutenait
l'association gaylib et le mariage
homosexuel pendant la campagne
présidentielle et qui aujourd'hui
s'affiche comme le candidat anti mariage
pour tous une courte séquence qualifié
de trucage par l'intéressé d'autant plus
choqué que selon lui cette vidéo aurait
été envoyée aux militants de l'ump grâce
à des fichiers d'adhérents piratés
claude goasguen député ump du xvième
arrondissement de paris et soutien de
nathalie kosciusko morizet est nommément
accusé de relayer cette vidéo auprès de
ses contacts
jean françois legaret a décidé de porter
plainte contre x pour faux et usage de
faux
monsieur claude goasguen sera évidemment
possible des poursuites que j'engage
pour usage de faux et je demande à l'ump
là aussi de prendre des mesures on sait
que monsieur claude goasguen est une
grande gueule je demande qu'il la ferme
jusqu'à la fin du scrutin dont claude
goasguen c'est assez violent voulu
répondre directement servi de ces
fichiers tout simplement voilà la
question et pas du tout mais je suis
pour rien dans cette histoire moins
visibles mais mon travail c'est lui qui
a commis d'erreur doit envoyer un
communiqué à l'ensemble des arrêtés
rangs ump pour dire qu'il était victime
d'une malfaçon présumé d'ailleurs parce
qu'il n'a pas montré de résultat des
courses qu'est ce qu'on fait les
adhérents ump dans deux mais qu'est ce
que c'est cette vidéo c'est la plus sûre
manière de faire connaître cette vidéo
dernier continue mais vous allez envoyer
il avait envoyé cette vidéo mais bien
sûr pas aux adhérents de l'ump
moi je suis délégué de la plus grosse
section de paris qu'en mai à des roms
demande des renseignements je leur donne
parce qu'ils avaient tous reçu le très
franchement je souhaite comme suit le
garrec porte plainte
donc je ne souhaite vraiment pas ce
qu'il va savoir ce que c'est que la
justice et celui qu'elle n'aura
peut-être les propos et on sent quand
même que le taux est très violent
n'aurait violent mais côté il est en fin
de campagne
je crois qu'il est en train de perdre il
s'agace c'est tout à fait normal
ça démarre très mal ça commençait très
mal ça finira mal mais alors
que monsieur le gard et soit d'abord
vous savez quand on est un élu politique
on perd pas son sang froid
donc ce scrutin a commencé c'est en ce
moment depuis ce vendredi matin et
jusqu'à lundi 19 heures les adhérents de
l'ump peuvent aller voter lorsqu'ils se
sont inscrits il ya ce problème entre
vous il ya aussi apprennent
d'organisation visiblement le moins
qu'on puisse dire c'est que c'est un on
va en parler la fédération par exemple a
décidé de laisser ouvertes les
inscriptions des militants tout le
week-end alors qu'eux mêmes alors même
que le scrutin est en cours ça a été
décidé sans l'avis de tous les candidats
alors je dis on a constaté que c'était
la tournée des candidats mécontents on
les écoute on les regarde elles ont
changé les règles du jeu en cours de ce
scrutin
et bien que j'appelle les parisiens à
s'en saisir et j'appelle les parisiens
allaient dire massivement dans les urnes
qu'il ne supporte plus ces vieilles
méthodes d'une droite parisienne qui a
trop échoué et je suis face à cela le
candidat du renouvellement
j'accuse les apprentis sorciers et les
officines
cette primaire on veut manifestement la
torpiller par tous les moyens au mépris
des électeurs
ces primaires ça devait être une gêne à
dire une course 1
et puis le plus rapide allait aller
gagner et il se trouve que on met plein
de fils de nylon pour faire tomber les
gens aient enfin la campagne allait
souvent au moment de polémique donc
c'est pas la peine non plus su réagir
sur les unes sur les autres parce que
c'est pas ça qui fait le coeur qui fait
l'intérêt de la campagne pour tout vous
avouer monsieur goasguen nous
journalistes étions un peu sidérée de
ses points presse qui ont eu lieu jeudi
où on affiche ouvertement son
mécontentement l'ump est reprise par ses
vieux démons dans l'impression au niveau
local de retrouver ce qui s'est passé au
niveau national en décembre est vrai que
les primaires alors la plus pure phrase
tout général
c'est vrai que la notion de primaires à
l'ump il va falloir faire une pédagogie
de la primaire c'est pas sain pour une
raison très simple d'ailleurs c'est que
nos électeurs ne sont pas comme les
électeurs de gauche habituée aux débats
idéologiques et adoré discuter non ce
sont des électeurs de tendance plutôt
bonapartiste opération fait partie
et d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'ils nous
disent 10 mail si vous faites des
primaires si vous êtes divisés
mettez vous d'accord et puis après on
suivra celui le principe ne sont pas les
militants là ça c'est lui le plus ce
sont des gens qui en fin de campagne
c'est toujours comme ça les fans
campagne très franchement je crois qu'il
faut pas surréagir
ça fait partie du folklore ça veut dire
ça mais la passion vous entends bien que
ces primaires elles ont écouté les
primaires informatique terminé alors ça
terminé parce que pour s'inscrire aux
primaires il faut avoir une patience
exceptionnel d'abord parce que ça ça
marche pas ensuite il faut s'inscrire et
puis après il faut voter il faudra
encore voir une patience extraordinaire
puisque encore hier on a été obligé de
changer un logiciel bon tout ça est
assez
si on se trompe pas c'est bien la
fédération de paris qui a décidé
d'annoncer le national la fédération de
parler parce qu'ils avaient pas d'argent
enfin bref si on entend bien ce que vous
dites quand même nicolas cusco morizet
quelques clics que vous soutenez 80 de
chances d'être j'ai ma part de dire je
suis en vie
est-ce qu'elle sera légitime après un
tel scrutin écoutez en virage vous savez
de là on passe déjà en passe des choses
je viens de me renseigner sur la manière
dont ça s'est passé à londres
ça m'a rassuré parce qu'ils ont fait
aussi des primaires ouvertes ils ont eu
vingt mille inscrits ça n'a pas empêché
le maire de lons d'être élu vingt mille
inscrits il fallait 60
je vous en prie dans 50 villes les états
marathon et elle vous voyez ça n'a pas
empêché le maire actuel de londres avec
vingt mille inscrits dans la primaire
d'être élu maire de jean-pierre sur ces
grands principes du primaire on dit que
c'est le retour de la machine à perdre
la droite la plus bête du monde nous
frapper tout ça fait très longtemps
qu'on parle de ça voilà c'est vous les
avez entendu là c'est les mêmes il va y
suit le jeune et j'ai refuge aux
militants les mêmes défauts feugas
viennent on va dérouler ensemble tout le
fil de l'actualité a aussi parlé de
l'ump et du voyage pour tous encore une
fois l'ump a encore du mal à parler
d'une même voix sur un autre thème le
mariage pour tous fallait il participe
et la manifestation faudra-t-il
supprimer la loi en cas de retour au
pouvoir dimanche valérie brochard a
suivi dans la manifestation l'un des
vice-présidents de l'ump guillaume
pelletier l'un des plus fervents
opposants au mariage pour tous et pas
toujours bien vus au sein de son propre
camp va le voir il arrive seul et
marchera seul le vice président de l'ump
a choisi de défiler
loin des élus pour être au plus proche
des manifestants
cette manifestation sera pour lui la
dernière le temps de la rue est passé il
faut maintenant penser aux urnes
la rue c'est bien pour alerter les mais
ce qui compte fondamentalement c'est
l'engagement politique c'est
l'engagement électoral pour changer des
choses dans une évocation change les
choses par les urnes et pas par la rue
si la droite reprendre pouvoir la loi
sur le mariage homosexuel sera réécrite
film loi aujourd'hui nous la jugeons
mauvaise il faudra bien entendu la ré
écrire demain dont le respect des
personnes et moi je crois que même
ségolène royal l'a dit hier on peut très
bien transformer le cette loi en union
civile strictes en excluant l'adoption
parce que ça permettra de consacrer
justement le droit pour chaque enfant
d'avoir un père et une mère
une intention pas toujours partagée à
droite françois fillon par exemple
affirme qu'il ne reviendra jamais en
arrière
les militants craignent une fracture à
l'ump ont bien d'autres choses mais dans
le respect des autres
guillaume pepy avait mis en cause la
candidature de nathalie kosciusko
morizet à paris à cause de son
abstention sur le mariage pour tous très
remonté henri guaino fait la leçon au
jeune vice président que chacun essaie
de se tenir depuis jeté vais dire une
préférence de bombes et les raisons de
le dire autrement
tendu pour 10 autrement c'est là c'est
peut-être la seule la seule discipline
malgré les écarts d'opinion l'objectif
reste clair rassembler et surtout
grossir les rangs de l'ump pour les
élections présidentielles de 2017
reste encore à harmoniser les discours
et affiné l'argumentaire commun claude
goasguen nous avions chez l'attaquant
henri guaino donne ça titre le son à
guillaume pelletier des trop loin c'est
une manifestation toutes les
manifestations bon je pense que la
réécriture est possible difficile
impudiquement parce que nous ne sommes
pas les seuls à légiférer il à la cour
européenne de justice
il est bien évidemment que c'est un il
est bien évident que c'est un handicap
alors on ne peut pas évidemment faire
une loi rétroactive abrogation c'est
impossible c'est impossible
juridiquement ça fait bien parce que ça
sonne bien abrogation c'est un couple
qui est un petit côté révolte et
révolutionnaire mais un juridiquement
bien ça dépend pour qui
non mais ça sonne bien ça sonne bien
mettez les gens de gauche et 10
abrogation s'appelait à la problème
c'est que c'est pas si simple parce que
la cour européenne interviendra
moi je suis en train de travailler
justement pour le groupe ump sur les
possibilités juridiques que nous avons
elles sont pas faciles mais il faudra le
faire existent où elles existent où il
existe d'abord on pourrait peut-être
modifier le préambule de la constitution
qui a besoin singulièrement d'être
rafraîchis pour rappeler que le ce qu'a
dit le conseil constitutionnel
d'ailleurs que le droit à l'enfant n'est
pas le droit de l'enfant et à partir de
là on peut dérouler une législation qui
sont remettre en compte rétroactivement
les choses permettrait d affiner vers un
contrat d'union civile parce que le
problème n'est pas tellement d'ailleurs
de faire venir la mairie ou des
problèmes du mariage c'est que la france
a un système de mariage et un système de
droit familial
issu de la révolution française quand on
a viré l'église de l'état civil et du
mariage et c'est ce qui fait la grande
différence et les grandes difficultés en
france par rapport à l'espagne 4 de
mariage un mariage civil
et puis un mariage religieux qui ont la
même valeur juridique donc c'est très
compliqué
revenir un petit peu sur ces
manifestations est celle qui a eu lieu
le week end dernier vous étiez présent
et on sent quand même qu'il y a une
division au sein même de votre parti
parce que il y avait laurent wauquiez
qui était là il y avait jean françois
copé et chacun se renvoie la balle hors
d or récupération politicienne
moi je ne suis pas favorable à ce terme
de récupération
je suis d'autant moins que la
manifestation qui était composé de gens
vraiment de droite bon enfant c'était
une manifestation très agréable très
franchement
mais ce mouvement le d'abord j'en fais
rien parce que c'est aux gens de se
décider mais la récupération a donné
lieu à des propos qui étaient des propos
d'infiltration on a vu apparaître en
réalité des gens qui souvent étaient les
battus des élections des gens d'extrême
droite qui essayait de récupérer ce beau
monde qui arrivait dans les rues c'est
la raison pour laquelle j'étais
sceptique sur l'idée qu'il fallait
qu'ils adhèrent à l'ump ou pas l'ump
voteront comme ils veulent pas de
candidat aux municipales sur un jeu mais
surtout je suis je suis pas là s'ils
font ils le font si vous voulez je pense
que c'est une erreur parce que ça
montrerait quand même que françois
hollande a réussi son pari de diviser
les français d'abord et puis de diviser
la droite ensuite sur des sujets de
société les socialistes savent faire ça
il nous agite déjà le vote des courges
oui il faut pas tomber dans le panneau
cela étant moi je suis pas là pour dire
aux gens surtout le fait pas ils le font
parce que j'y réfléchisse exemple
parisien il ya beaucoup de 2,2
d'adhérents mais prévient lors de la
manif pour tous je crois que déjà il a
beaucoup ne crois pas non non
franchement non je crois pas mais en
tout cas certains des candidats et c'est
tout le problème de la polémique est née
se sont découvert des vertus et même
aussi cette question avec ses mouvements
aujourd'hui qui va changer un petit peu
de forme
ils vont décider de faire du harcèlement
contre les mines estime bercy
manifester quand il y aura un mariage
qu'est ce qu'ils en pensaient c'est
absurde enfin c'est absurde c'est
désormais la loi de la république
moi je ne ferais pas les mariages mais
mes adjoints font les mariages j'en ai
discuté avec eux la loi de la république
sera appliquée dans la mairie je ne
m'estimais pas vous mais je ne fais pas
je suis d'accord avec mes adjoints
j'en ai discuté avec eux très librement
c'est un choix que chacun a fait très
bien
la loi la clause de conscience non
puisque ça a été refusé on aurait pu
imaginer la clause de conscience cela
étant la loi sera appliquée parce que je
suis l'officier d'état civil de la
mairie et je ne me sens pas disponible
pour violer la loi
mais ces harcèlements tout ça je trouve
ça vraiment super flics n entre que
j'avais vu peut-être vu l'image cette
semaine comme on sait pas comment ne pas
l'avoir vu en tout cas c'était
l'événement de la semaine ils se sont
dits oui premier mariage entre deux
hommes vincent et bruno la presse du
monde entier s'étaient donné rendez-vous
pour l'occasion vous avez vu sur ces
images la présence de la porte parole du
gouvernement à titre privé at elle dit
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la prévert
de la jatte vallaud belkacem
ouais bon je ne pense rien c'est se
priver
c'est le cas de google a le droit de
faire ce qu'elle veut je vais pas juger
avant du gouvernement
moi ce qui m'a paru étonnant scellant le
l'entrevue vraiment l'intérêt que cette
manifestation dans le monde entier a
suscité comme si véritablement la france
était un cas à part alors qu'à des
mariages homosexuels partout le monde
entier s'est braquée sur la france a eu
un débat beaucoup plus parce que c'est
un grosse manifestation parce que au
fond le monde s'est dit mais pourquoi
est ce que les français
le manifeste comme ça dans les rues sur
quelque chose que pour beaucoup de pays
européens on considère comme normal
c'est ce que je vous dis c'est que l'un
des fils et six normales aia mais
justement parce que le droit français
mais dans une manivelle cgc me répondre
c'est le droit français n'est pas le
même que le droit des autres pays
européens
en angleterre en espagne est partout
vous avez plusieurs possibilités
d'accéder au mariage ce ne sont pas les
mêmes mariage en france nous sommes
monolithique depuis la révolution
française et donc quand vous parlez de
mariage mariage entre un d'adoption
mariage entre elles tout les mêmes
droits non pas du tout pas du tout en
angleterre c'est pas du tout le cas en
espagne c'est pas du tout le cas
donc c'est beaucoup plus facile parce
qu'en réalité vous avez un mariage qui
est autorisé pour les homosexuels vous
avez vu le départ en angleterre
et puis ou si vous voulez pas de mariage
homosexuel vous marier à l'église ou
bien chez le pasteur ou bien dans
l'église anglicane la france de ce point
de vue est beaucoup plus crispé sur le
droit familial on vous manifestiez
beaucoup plus contre l'adoption contre
le match je crois qu'on a on a peut-être
commis une erreur voyez je fais mon auto
non
autocritique de ne pas suivre j'ai été
un des plus farouches opposants à
nicolas sarkozy sur cette question de ne
pas suivre peut-être le schéma du
contrat de contrat d'union civile qui
avait été proposé par nicolas sarkozy en
2007 si on avait fait ça on aurait sans
doute évité nous aussi ce genre de
problème voyez à tout péché miséricorde
je reconnais que sans doute on aurait pu
éviter cette division artificielle et et
grave sur le plan social que que le
débat sur le mariage pour tous à
discuter de questions sur ce thème là
dans le 16e arrondissement vous avez eu
des demandes de mariage ou par non pas
pour l'instant pas pour l'instant on
verra ça plus tard
allez on va passer au mardi encore
parler de l'ump oui cette semaine ump
très présents l'ump qui s'est vue d'une
nouvelle guerre des chefs à l'automne
soit une bonne douche après sa victoire
très contesté jean françois copé devait
remettre son titre en jeu en septembre
prochain son titre de président de l'ump
les deux rivaux copé fillon en ont
finalement décidé autrement ils vont
demander aux militants dans un petit
mois s'ils veulent d'un nouveau vote ils
savent bien que non germain andrieu
l'accord est enfin officiel mais fidèle
à ses habitudes pas un mot de françois
fillon à la presse
a priori pas de nouveau vote en
septembre les militants majoritairement
hostile à un nouveau scrutin devront
trancher fin juin bien plus qu'une
sortie de crise à moins d'un an des
élections municipales
c'est un soulagement pour l'opposition
le monde était d'accord ce matin il ya
une unanimité pour dire c'est une sortie
par le haut et on se trompe jamais donné
la parole aux militants
c'est une très bonne chose c'est un bon
accord d'autant que françois fillon et
jean françois copé montre une image
unitaire on a très bon accord qui va
permettre de calmer le jeu et c'était
l'essentiel donc le mandat de kopeïsk en
2015 on fait les élections municipales
et après on verra
pourtant quelques voix discordantes se
font déjà entendre bernard acoyer
souligne un problème de gouvernance
laurent wauquiez dénonce l'absence de
leadership et souhaite un nouveau
scrutin après les élections européennes
du côté de jean françois copé il n'y a
plus de débat la prochaine élection ne
sera pas avant la fin de son mandat en
novembre 2015 une problème de l'ump
c'est moins un problème de gouvernance
et le leadership que d'ego points
si on pouvait jouer un peu collectif
nous sommes à à peine un an de la
dernière élection présidentielle
nous avons été défait c'est la période
qui est la plus difficile la plus
douloureuse je constate que nous nous
reconstruisons et et l'accord que nous
avons conclu ensemble avec françois
fillon on est une démonstration
supplémentaire pas de nouvelle guerre
des chefs donc avant la primaire de 2016
seuls les militants pourront trancher
lors d'un référendum à terme prévu fin
juin
alors on se serait presque réjoui pour
l'ump un accord enfin trouvé puis boum
voilà l'artillerie lourde quand même des
fillonistes qui ressort manque de
leadership prem de gouvernance dit
bernard acoyer par exemple c'est une
c'est une plaie de pure forme finalement
sur le fond ça continue quels sont les
pays qui ne sont pas de pures formes on
vous ment présenterez une non il ya il
ya eu non sans mal on a mis quand même
un peu en bémol cette malheureuse
malheureuse campagne avec les primaires
du mois de décembre l'année dernière
ça nous a beaucoup marqué ça a beaucoup
marqué les militants on a trouvé un
compromis qui est acceptable pour tous
est quand même en chef à l'ump il ya
deux chefs disons mais il ya un
président qui est jean françois copé qui
s'entend avec françois fillon s'est
plutôt mieux que ce qu'on a connu au
mois de novembre mais mal élu mais il
n'a pas été mal élu c'est vous qui le
dites il est élu d'été lui les
présidents il travaille avec françois
fillon elle seule elle dira françois
fillon l'a dit pendant des mois et
devrait menaïl déplu c'est parfait la
corde
c'est un compromis maintenant il faut
que le
mp ce matin travail quoi parce que
maintenant les histoires personnelles
comme l'a dit chatel les histoires d'égo
ça suffit maintenant il faut
véritablement prendre le mors aux dents
et puis essayer de contrer efficacement
ce gouvernement en matière économique et
sociale vous êtes sans doute vu
l'express cette semaine
toutefois par will qui parle qui enfonce
le clou un qui voit ligne de fracture à
l'ump
ils dénoncent l' influence nos cibles du
très droitier patrick buisson difficile
pour l'ump c'est patrick buisson c'est
pelletier c'est un débat est également
jean françois copé
il conseille tout le monde il a même
conseillé à mon avis françois fillon il
ya quelques années ça c'est pas le
problème de la personnalité de 800 c'est
ce qu'ont fait dire un buisson je sais
pas ce qu'ils pensent de moi je dois pas
me suis régalé ces questions de ligne
cette question est résolue nous ne
serons pas les alliés du front national
encore une fois on remettrait sur l'airé
françois baroin trouve sans doute que la
droitisation de l'ump est excessive mais
droitisation ou pas il n'y aura pas
d'accord avec le front national c'est
comme ça notre parti est un parti de
gouvernement pluraliste où il ya des
libéraux des gaullistes des démocrates
chrétiens c'est le point le commun
dénominateur c'est que nous avons
vocation à gouverner ensemble dans notre
diversité sans entendent avec le front
national qui est complètement à linverse
de nous ils sont contre l'europe mais
pour l'europe ils sont ils sont dans
cette situation parce qu'ils ont oublié
son populisme ne sont pas populiste
je ne lui aura pas d'accord il n'y aura
pas d'accord à l'afghane votre principal
problème à l'ump c'est pas cette
question qu'on n'arrête pas rappelé
depuis un an fait du droit d'inventaire
de nicolas sarkozy question et à mon
avis c'est une question que nous posons
mal je vais vous le dire très
sincèrement je crois qu'on a besoin de
faire une analyse de notre défaite et
les élections sans doute on était trop
précipité
nicolas sarkozy qui va vous verrez
nicolas sarkozy actuellement doit doit
se gausser de l'attitude de l'ump c'est
lui qui le fera lui même
nicolas sarkozy n'est pas assez fou pour
dire eh bien écoutez j'ai perdu par
hasard il sait très bien parce que c'est
un homme politique quels sont les
éléments qui l'ont fait perdre et donc
c'est dans
nature d'un homme politique mur est
responsable de se dire voilà ce qui n'a
pas marché
est ce que je ne devrait plus faire si
d'aventuré ils voudraient prendre des
responsabilités
et voilà ce que l'ump devrait faire
tranquillement parce que s'avérer une
crédibilité à l'ump que l'ump aura du
mal à retrouver sans cet aspect des
choses parce qu'il faut expliquer
pourquoi tranquillement savez une
défaite ça arrive et puis on est petit
pourquoi et puis on essaye de
reconstruire différemment
c'est pour ça mon avis que d'ailleurs la
l'élection du mois de l'année dernière
n'a pas été une réussite parce que sans
cette phase préalable vous pouvez
difficilement dessiner des lignes et des
signes et des leaders de partis
je crois qu'il faudra la faire il faudra
la faire calmement il faudra la faire
avec nicolas sarkozy je l'espère mais il
faudra la faire passer à autre chose ça
pourrait être un nouveau désaveu pour
françois hollande la réforme du conseil
supérieur de la magistrature
elle est débattue à l'assemblée
nationale visiblement il n'y a aucune
chance pour arriver à la majorité des
trois cinquièmes pourtant nécessaire
pour aller jusqu'au congrès à versailles
toutes les explications de betty
lachguer c'est l'engagement numéro 53 de
françois hollande son objectif rendre la
justice plus indépendante
parmi les principales mesures la
composition du conseil supérieur de la
magistrature pourrait être modifié
aujourd'hui il est formé de huit
personnalités qualifiées et de sept
magistrats
le projet de loi prévoit la répartition
inverse avec désormais une majorité de
magistrats mais l'égalité pourrait
finalement l'emporter la commission des
lois ayant présenté un amendement dans
ce sens
autre nouveauté ces personnes qualifiées
pourrait être désigné non plus par le
pouvoir politique mais par un collège
indépendant collège composé notamment du
président la cour des comptes et du
défenseur des droits
il nommerait alors le président du csm
parmi ces personnalités
enfin les attributions du conseil
supérieur de la magistrature seront
renforcés tout magistrat pourra bientôt
saisir le csm sur une question de
déontologie qui le concerne des avancées
selon le syndicat la magistrature mais
qui ne vont pas encore assez loin
nous sommes dans un système
le lien reste très fort entre le pouvoir
exécutif la garde des sceaux et les
magistrats notamment ceux du parquet il
est dans ces conditions de ciment
indispensable effectivement de renforcer
l'indépendance des magistrats
malheureusement sur une des questions
les plus essentielles celle de la
nomination des magistrats on reste très
en deçà le vote de ce texte aura lieu le
4 juin prochain l'assemblée nationale
mais pour être définitivement adoptée
après le vote des deux chambres
cette réforme constitutionnelle devra
réunir le vote de trois cinquièmes des
parlementaires réunis cet été en congrès
à versailles
l'ump a voté contre claude goasguen où
ils avaient voté contre
oui oui bien sûr on ne garde pas donc de
discuter franchement cette réforme du
csm et ça vaut pas le coup quoi c'est
une mini réforme il valait mieux garder
le système actuel on change quoi une
personne de perche aussi ça parce qu'il
faut peut-être expliquer un petit peu
moins de quoi et ça je fais c'est la maj
à jauger les magistrats obama assistera
un personnes qui sont des gens
compétents qui font partie du csm ont
sauté resté vide voilà aux sociétés ceux
qui sont société civile ou bien
magistrat bon moi je trouve que ce qu'on
avait mis en place alors avec une
réforme donnée quand même donné quand
même le sentiment que les choses étaient
sérieuses dans les pouvoirs il ya
toujours il faut toujours éviter quand
même le corporatisme des magistrats
c'est quelque chose de très puissant
l'aperçu des personnalités civiles à
côté c'est très bien franchement la
réforme était équilibré n'avait pas
besoin de ce truc
il n'y avait rien volé un peu bidon
quand même permettez-moi de le dire
parce que l'indépendance du parquet
comme ça ça tisse toujours pratiqué
comme ça c'est la pluie présent dans la
nomination des membres et non mais c'est
très bien mais bon jeu il a toujours été
en réalité beaulieu il ya eu très peu
d'accidents
et puis il ya la publication des
circulaires et des instructions je
rappelle que le parquet publication ou
pas le parquet la plume est serve mais
la parole est libre c'est à dire qu'en
toute hypothèse un procureur fait ce
qu'il veut et croyez moi les procureurs
ne sont pas des gens soumis par exemple
je voudrais qu'on parle d'une procureure
financiers fsa sera un jour pourquoi
avoir fait un procureur financier
pourquoi alors que tous les pros coeur
sont chargés de toutes les atteintes aux
droits pourquoi un procureur financier
engendré les affaires politico
financières et je ne pouvais pas
dessaisi
un procureur de saint le procureur de
paris est parfaitement compétent la
magistrature et est vent debout contre
cette histoire de spécialisation par
matière d'un procureur qui sera nommé
par le président de la république et on
peut suspecter qui ne sera pas nommé par
ses ennemis qui arrivent dans deux
semaines voilà mais c'est le même style
vous avez ce sont des réformes
je trouve que on est tombé dans la
période de la moralisation entre
guillemets et on fait beaucoup d'erreurs
on fait beaucoup d'erreurs de
communication dans un pays qui est déjà
très très difficile à gouverner à cause
des problèmes sociaux on a vu que les
centristes vont être contre ce test n'y
a pas que les centristes qui pose
problème au gouvernement
il y a aussi les écologistes qui cette
semaine ont décidé de jouer les rebelles
à l'assemblée ils ont voté ce mardi
contre le projet de loi du gouvernement
sur l'enseignement supérieur à
l'unanimité et c'est une première depuis
le début du quinquennat jérémy hartmann
c'est une première depuis le début du
quinquennat de françois hollande hier
dans l'hémicycle les députés du groupe
écologiste ont voté à l'unanimité contre
un texte présenté par le gouvernement
celui sur l'enseignement supérieur et la
recherche
alors faut-il y voir la fin du pacte
majoritaire entre écologistes et
socialistes
la porte parole du groupe préfère parler
de désaccord ponctuelles nous sommes des
partenaires de la majorité
nous votons d'ailleurs les budgets ce
qui est évident quand on est dans la
majorité on n'a jamais dit que on
voterait tous les tests de la majorité
il n'empêche ces derniers mois les
écologistes peine à exister dans les
médias et surtout dans les décisions
politiques de la majorité
la soumission c'est la pire des choses
en politique donc oui il faut que nous
fassions entendre une sur cette question
de l'université nous le disons mais nous
aurons sans doute d'autres occasions
d'affirmer notre singularité
à un an des municipales les écologistes
tentent de marquer leurs différences et
n'hésitent plus à hausser le ton
n'est-il pas temps monsieur le ministre
de changer de cap à l'assemblée mais
aussi au sénat et à la tête du parti
c'est d'ailleurs pascal durand qui le
premier a sonné la charge contre le
gouvernement la semaine dernière dans
une interview au journal libération
arnaud montebourg manuel valls bernard
cazeneuve des réactionnaires
conservateur dit il même delphine batho
en prend pour son grade
la ministre de l'écologie est accusé de
ne pas se faire entendre de perdre les
arbitrages notamment en matière de
fiscalité écologique une charge que les
responsables socialistes disent avoir
entendu il faut d'abord prendre au
sérieux cette petite alerte et peut-être
travailler mieux avec le groupe
écologiste que nous avons su le faire
pour l'instant
sincère ou calculs et la stratégie de
l'apaisement semble fonctionner pour
l'instant les écologistes souhaitent
maintenir leur participation au
gouvernement dont claude gouazé nous
vous regarder tout ça de l'extérieur
mais les écologistes commencent à
critiquer ils doivent quitter le
gouvernement cherche à me dire çà doit
aux façades a poussé oui oui mais il ya
aussi quand on était dans la majorité
entre les groupes quittant son président
était très discipliné n'ont pas toujours
mais ça peut poser aussi une fois à b sa
biographie son gouvernement est critiqué
je crois à ce que je crois pas mais
enfin on verra bien si tout cela se
poursuit si ça se poursuit ce posera un
problème supplémentaire aux gouvernants
qu'elle n'a déjà pas mal sam 06 comme
par les deux municipalités laquelle des
négociations surnommait / 100 g sûrement
je le sens je sens qu'il ya une odeur de
mulhouse c'est comme ça oui je sens
qu'il ya une odeur de municipal les
écologistes veulent exister aux
municipales font ils des listes séparées
des listes communes
tout ça à billets sur sur une oie qui
était noir l'enseignement supérieur qui
par ailleurs est mauvaise mais pas pour
les mêmes raisons
nous avons voté contre mais pas pour les
mêmes raisons que les écologistes bon
tout ça tout ça est cousu de fil blanc
ou de file vers les ont pas ce mercredi
on va parler économie on va surtout
parler de bruxelles et françois hollande
qui n'apprécient pas les recommandations
faites par bruxelles
le président de la république qui est
bien décidée à durcir le ton contre la
pression faite par bruxelles qui demande
plus de réformes et le président de la
république est pris en tenaille parce
que en france également
didier migaud le président de la cour
des comptes fait lui aussi des
recommandations
il faut aller plus vite plus loin plus
fort les détails avec jérôme rabier
l'économie française est dans l'oeil du
cyclone après la cour des comptes et la
banque de france hier place aujourd'hui
à la commission européenne et elle
demande à la france des efforts
substantiels pour réduire son déficit
si la commission confirme le délai de
deux années supplémentaires pour
repasser sous la barre des 3% du pib
elle demande en contrepartie une réforme
des retraites avant la fin de l'année
la mise en oeuvre d'une réforme du
marché du travail ou encore l'ouverture
de professions réglementées comme les
taxis ou les notaires
jean marc ayrault ne peut qu'acquiescer
même s'il y met des nuances il n'y a pas
de surprise
3 que nous sommes dans la droite ligne
de ce qui avait déjà été annoncé et donc
la france va respecter ses engagements
ce qui implique un certain nombre de
réformes que nous ferons à un autre
manière plus tôt dans la journée didier
migaud était venu présenter son
évaluation des comptes de l'état pour
l'an dernier et s'il note des efforts
dans la maîtrise des comptes publics
ces préconisations ressemble à s'y
méprendre à celle de bruxelles
nous constatons effectivement un effort
de maîtrise de la de la dépense selon la
technique du rabot mais nous disons que
cette technique la has et limitent donc
nous invitons les pouvoirs publics à
prendre des mesures plus structurelles
opposition et majorité semble d'accord à
force de se l'entendre dire les
parlementaires promettent une
mobilisation générale sur la maîtrise du
budget françois hollande est très classe
et pas à bruxelles de nous dicter notre
politique mais est ce que dans les faits
c'est pas tout autre pont je trouve
d'abord que la commission a été très
maladroite dans son expression et que
françois hollande il ya trouvé une
manière intelligente de réagir et de
donner donc ce sentiment que la france
ne se soumettra jamais l'europe met
enfin en réalité même si l'attitude
politicienne
net intelligente la réalité est tout
autre en réalité au fond l'allemagne
nous a accordé deux ans de
condescendance charitable et ne sommes
pas dans une position très bonne
cela étant je trouve que la commission
européenne en se conduisant comme ça
donne véritablement le bâton pour se
faire battre
s'occupant des taxis étaient la
commission européenne assure suivre les
indications de bruxelles non mais c'est
une bonne question
c'est juste sur la rue celle de la cour
des comptes du gouverneur de la banque
de france c'est le contraire de la
politique de françois hollande juge
comprend que françois d'inventaire tout
à l'heure ses réformes structurelles
sont des réformes de fond sur grande
longueur qu'on aurait pu n'a pas les
dépenses publiques c'est l'impôt ne
rentre plus
moi je suis à la commission des finances
qu'est ce que nous a dit mikko il nous a
dit qu'en réalité nous avions fait 12
milliards d'impôts supplémentaires sur
lequel il y en avait six qui ne
rentraient pas parce que la croissance
évidemment ou d'un moment la
décroissance freine la rentrée de
l'impôt c'est à dire qu'on est dans une
espèce de spirale folle qui va nous
pousser à augmenter des impôts parce que
les enfants rentrent moins bien et en
augmentant l'impôt voulons rentrer de
moins en moins bien
l'impôt a un effet au bout d'un moment
destructeur c'était on avait dit ça ya
dix quinze ans mais on l'a jamais
appliquée même si je reconnais que la
droite n'est pas non plus vierge sur ce
sujet c'était trop d'impôt tué l'impôt
et en ce moment nous sommes dans une
dérive fiscales qui ne s'accompagne pas
de diminution de la dépense publique car
l'impôt vient en réalité combler la
dépense publique qui continue à
augmenter
et encore nous sommes dans un système où
nous étions faut il faut il faut mais il
ya des solutions structurelles mais il
faut il faut diminuer la dépense
publique il faut diminuer les dépenses
publiques mais ton mais mais mais ce que
dit aussi vous l'avez vu le président à
la wii la wii mais il faut le faire il
faut pas se contenter de le dire il faut
le faire c'est difficile et mesures qui
sont en classe on a supprimé cette idée
qu'on fallait remplacer un fonctionnaire
sur deux on l'a fait ça nous a permis
d'ailleurs d'éponger une partie de la
dépense publique est de permettre au
gouvernement actuel d'avoir une
stabilisation des dépenses publiques
mais comme ça va être abandonné la
dépense publique va remonter
nous ne pourrons pas aller vers une
croissance il ne diminueront pas le taux
d'impôt si nous ne diminuons pas la
dépense publique et s'ils ne donnant pas
aux investisseurs la possibilité de
faire des crédits l'emploi ça ne se
décrète pas on peut faire les contrats
d'avenir
les contrats de génération quand un chef
d'entreprise sait qu'il va être en
difficulté pour vendre il recrute pas
vous pouvez même lui faire des droits
des effets d'aubaine il ne recrutera par
les mesures qui sont annoncées en ce
moment sur les familles pour avaient
saccagé des fonds supplémentaires
pourquoi parce que vous allez faire une
modification du quotient familial et
probablement de des prestations pour les
plus fortunés
ça fait tellement de toucher au curry
non pas avec le quotient familial c'est
la classe moyenne qui dérouille c'est à
dire qu'en réalité on va faire un impôt
supplémentaire de 1 à 2 milliards
c'est clair ça l'est on peut on peut
rétablir tout à coup d'impôts mais il
arrive un moment où on n'en peut plus de
faire des réformes structurelles mais
dès qu'on touche à quelque chose à la
seule famille qui montent au créneau
mais non il se sera pas comment ton
prénom sait qu il ya d'autres solutions
pour relancer la croissance que
d'augmenter les impôts parce que si vous
vous augmentez les impôts les gens
dépensent moins
s'ils dépensent moins vous fait de la
décroissance il faut diminuer les
dépenses publiques d'une manière
drastique
il faut et pas il faut écouter ce que
dit le président socialiste de la cour
des comptes où le gouverneur de la
banque de france et pas se soumettre à
barroso
c'est du bon sens et moi je trouve que
les allemands ne sont pas
particulièrement vertueux ils ont du bon
sens et c'était chanteur qui a eu le bon
sens que d'ailleurs françois hollande a
encensé ce qui ne manquait pas de sel
devant le congrès du parti social
démocrate la question sur le plan
économique
est ce que tout le monde en tout cas
l'air sceptique sur le retournement du
chômage entre la courbe du chômage
la fin de l'année scolaire sceptiques
est ce qu est ce qu on ne croirait pas
le président la pluie condamne pas su
gérer parce que le président de la
république n'est pas un magicien qui
avec une baguette magique est capable de
retourner une tendance qui est une
tendance forte
c'est clair qu' il n'y arrivera pas où
il y arrivera en créant des contrats
d'avenir à modifier c'est à dire qu'en
réalité c'est la fiscalité qui va partir
moi je souhaite qu'il réussisse un très
franchement s'ils pouvaient d'un coup de
baguette magique relancer l'emploi en
france
très heureux mais très franchement la
méthode employée non j'ai pas bonne elle
est pas bonne la méthode c'est au jeudi
ça chauffe au sénat pour le mois un
climat très électrique l'un des volets
du texte sur la décentralisation est
débattue il concerne la réforme des
collectivités exemple une grande ville
comme marseille pourrait évoluer au
profit de métropoles aix marseille
métropole avec des pouvoirs peut être un
petit peu plus limité pour les maires
les élus des bouches du rhône en tout
cas étaient tous présents dans
l'hémicycle au mois que l'on peut dire
c'est qu'il y avait de l'ambiance marie
brémaud alors que le débat sur les
métropoles vient à peine de commencer
un comité d'accueil attend la ministre
marylise lebranchu devant l'hémicycle
les élus des bouches du rhône de tous
bords les échos l'air pas cg mais je
vais le mettre le son c'est bien parce
qu'on veut nous tuer
dans la ligne de mire des élus la
création d'une vaste métropole autour de
marseille souhaitée par le gouvernement
le président de la commission des lois
jean pierre sueur a oeuvré activement
pour la réécriture du projet de loi
alors quand ils apparaissent il est
accueilli en héros
quelle meilleure que le mois de juin
l'ambiance est tout autre avec la
ministre de la décentralisation une
réunion s'improvise il faut désamorcer
le conflit avant la poursuite des débats
mais à l'issue d'une demi heure des
charges les élus sont visiblement
toujours aussi remonté je considère
qu'il n'y a eu aucune avancée
sinon un peu d'âme plumage et les
esprits s'échauffent n'y seront pas
l'image est symbolique dans l'après-midi
un sénateur et maire expriment leur
mécontentement devant les portes du
palais du luxembourg pas les bienvenus
mais désiré à faire bouger c'est pas en
faisant en sorte que toute la richesse
finalement tu n'es pas non plus
extraordinaire toute la richesse des
bouches du rhône et sur la ville de
marseille qu'on va sauver la ville de
marseille
ça veut dire que toutes ces compétences
qu'on donne à la métropole elles ne
pourront pas être assez d'assumer que le
budget de la métropole et qui va se
retrouver asséchées leur profil maximum
pour gérer au mieux nos communes ce sont
les alentours
jean claude gaudin seul contre tous
marseille métropole
il soutient le projet de loi et sa ville
marseille ne veut pas de donner de
leçons à qui que ce soit mais marseille
et n'a pas de leçon à recevoir de qui
que ce soit merci mais au delà du
vaudeville apparent c'est l'avenir de
tout un département qui est en train de
s'écrire au climat houleux mais il
faudrait faire votre avis texte
dangereux ou pas mais écoutez moi je
suis parisien alors je veux pas me mêler
les affaires marseillaise ça a l'air
assez compliqué comme ça mais moi je
suis favorable à la création d'une
métropole qui permettrait de mettre en
commun les moyens sans pour autant d
habiller comme on a l'air de le dire les
communes qui sont voisines est il vrai
que les maires par exemple perdre leurs
prérogatives
le pouvoir ni perte de pouvoir nous ça
se négocie tout ça il faut pas non plus
faire du cocardier on a besoin
franchement par exemple à paris je
trouve que faire paris métropole quelles
que soient les conditions c'est une idée
qu'on aurait dû avoir depuis très
longtemps trouvé comme avantage paris
finale de grand paris d'abord ça parce
que leur en parler d'abord il existe
entre nous c'est pas la peine de
l'inventer d'exister il existait avant
il existera toujours
venons en matière de logement mais non
parce que les communes ont tendance à
faire de l'intercommunalité séparer sans
pour autant être d'accord avec la
communauté parisienne et bien les gens
qui habitent à levallois il travaille à
paris ceux qui habitent à pantin il
vient à paris ou à levallois renvoie
bien qu'à une interconnexion permanente
enfin il faut de temps en temps aussi
qu'on colle à la règle
sur le logement sur l'environnement il
s'agit pas de déshabiller les communes
il s'agit de maintenant vous allez voter
pour ce rejeton d'amendé sans sortir du
sénat parce que j'ai été peu de temps
ministre de la décentralisation
c'est ce qu'il ya de plus compliqué à
faire alors je suppose que ça va durer
un petit bon bah oui ça lui a divisé en
trois absolument c'est terrible c'est
les problèmes de décentraliser à fond
sans terrible parce que cet état qui est
centralisé à des collectivités
territoriales qui veulent absolument
rester sur leur quant à soi corporatisme
c'est ça oui voyez un corporatisme
communal que jean pierre chevènement
avait réussi à à peu près modernisé avec
les agglomérations les collectifs sur
les plus loin quoi c'est clair je sais
bien que ça va se faire souffrir je veux
faire mulet d'ailleurs sur don de ce que
j'ai dit pour revenir juste un mot sur
le grand paris ça ne se verra pas le
jour avant 2017
oui oui on perd du temps parce que le
temps croyez moi vous avez vu d'ailleurs
la teneur des débats c'est
particulièrement passionné ça va être
pareil sur paris pour se mettre d'accord
il faudra bien quelques mois et quelques
difficultés c'est très difficile mais il
faut le faire franchement là il s'agit
pas de gauche ou de droite il y à des
nécessités qui dépasse quand même et les
familles la croix sur l'un jouant mais
bien sûr ça va être important
paris est une ville sûre densifier il
est clair qu'on ne peut pas imaginer une
politique du logement intelligent qui
permet à la classe moyenne et awa celle
m d'être gérée convenablement sinon ans
sinon ne sert pas la surface
alors il faudra passer des accords que
les plus riches payent pour les plus
pauvres très bien je suis d'accord mais
il faut le faire sinon sinon on
n'arrivera à une ville de paris qui sera
une ville décadente qui ne sera plus
attractive qui sera obstrué avec des
communes tout autour sans doute
florissante mais sur le grand paris tout
entier c'est le grand l'ombre quoi
imaginer la grande la puissance du grand
londres par rapport à la réforme qu'a
réussi dans la douleur d'ailleurs
margaret thatcher on a commencé avec
nous on finit avec londres j'ai bouclé
merci beaucoup m
venu sur ce plateau pour commenter
l'actualité de la semaine merci google
et nous on se retrouve là son prochaine
bonne semaine à tous